all right gentlemen i'm gonna bring us
back in from the commercial break i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna do it as if
as if um we're in south africa i'm gonna
do it in
an afrikaans accent well why south
africa you'll be yourself
out i'll tell you i'll tell you why in a
second let me just bring us back in for
this cover
okay okay ready okay i'm going to do it
like it's my south africans
great right these actually are you ready
here we go
welcome back to the trish tasteful cost
on the voice of africa radio network
i'm your host ladybeard here today with
more guests
connor gaunt and joey gentlemen how are
you
that's actually really good i gotta
think of south africa at the moment you
sound
you sound like my math teacher back in
high school was he south africa he was
very south average okay go on yeah
if you're like no he's not sad if any if
any africana were offended by my accent
i was not trying to appropriate your
culture
i'll let you know
i can't i have so
you know what this is like this is the
conversation equivalent of like changing
tabs
is a very badly produced map of the
world
okay so when i was buying shower
curtains from whichever shower coat
dispensary i was
buy from right probably wasn't amazon
because i'm too old so
i was i bought the cheapest one and it
was a very poorly produced map of the
world okay
and like it's like the borders are in
the wrong places the colors of the
countries bleed over the borders
things are spelt wrong and um one of the
things it does
is on a country it does not highlight
the biggest city
or the capital city it highlights some
other cities just some random other
cities are left out right so fritz is in
australia i think in australia they
managed to get canberra so that was
that was right at least they got the
capital yeah in japan sendai
and no other city right um and then uh
and then so then so then all right so
how does that lead to your afrikaans
accent
this this connection i want to see when
i'm
sitting on the toilet and i won't go
into detail about what's going on at the
time
we can imagine you can imagine yes um my
eye line is such
that i look directly at that bottom part
of africa on this map
so it's like south africa namibia
botswana right
right right right and on the south
africa because it's a dodgy map
there's no cape town there's no
johannesburg right but there is
um flinting
okay which is just some random town
blimp it's firstly it's fun to say
say it with me you try what isn't it
bloom planting bloom flame team that was
excellent
you say that a welsh accent
you know what that sounds like that
sounds like it sounds like something the
swedish chef would say on the muppets
this is a real place yeah it's a real
place it's the capital [ __ ]
privileged people laughing in africa
it's the capital of a part of south
africa called uh free state
okay this is the capital of that biggest
city
capital of free state and that's
everyone who's watching this from
bloomfield is like why it's so funny
and bloomflontine is um what i look at
when i'm sitting on the tv [ __ ] okay
okay
and so for that reason i did some
research on bloom fluently
okay and now my current my boom is south
africa
so so that's why you did the afrikaans
accent that's why i did the ephrata
collins accent
and you can call me i don't know an
africana surname what's a common
africana surname
you're asking us if i know dirt and dirt
and fault you can call me ladybird dirt
and fault
from here on in joey take it away i
don't i don't think i can take it away
we were on the we're on the left
you guys you guys from now on can never
give a [ __ ] for the amount of tangents
we go on because that was easily the
biggest tangent we've ever been on i was
about to say we're quite famous for
going on tangents
and i swear there's like tangents within
tangents within tan just like when you
tell a singer
that was like that was like moving on to
a different shape tangent has ever been
started as beautifully as my shower
that's the greatest start to attention
okay okay ready to start